Hi, my name is Jessica Claire.
And I'm a professional dating coach here in New York City,...
...for New York Dating Coach.
In this clip we're going to talk about how to handle rejection...
...when trying to meet women.
First and foremost, it's important for you to know...
...how many women there are out there.
Do not get attached to one idea...
...or to the idea of being with one woman.
If you go into a club, there are a hundred girls there.
It's safe to say there are at least 20 of those hundred girls that you'd be willing to date.
So, if one of them rejects you,...
...always keep in the back of your mind that there are 19 more...
...you might have a better chance with.
Also, don't blame yourself.
It might have nothing to do with you.
Rejection is something that people take personally...
...but that is most likely not personal.
She might already have a fella or maybe she's not even feeling up to even flirting that day.
She wants to be with her girlfriends.
Don't assume that the reason that she rejected you is for something that you did.
Also, get used to it.
Rejection is going to happen to you over and over, and over again in life.
And it's the way that you face that rejection...
...that's going to mean possibilities for you later on.
Thanks for listening. This has been Jessica Claire.